[Applause]
that's my impersonation of a fishing cat
which actually sounds more like this
it's a cat that loves water loves to
fish and lives in some of the most
unique and valuable ecosystems on earth
the wetlands and mangrove forests of
South and Southeast Asia aren't they
fishing awesome fishing cats are one of
about 40 species of wild cats like
tigers and lions only much smaller
they're probably around twice the size
of our average domestic cat in Indonesia
people call them Kuching baka which
literally translates to the cat of the
mangroves but I like to call them the
Tigers of the mangroves now we don't
know fishing cats as well as we do
Tigers but what we've learned is that
these cats can be a flagship species to
a globally important ecosystem and a
visual bait attached to a strong line
for conservation are you hooked yet like
many endangered species fishing cats are
threatened by habitat loss mainly
because of our international demand for
farmed fish and shrimp and the
deforestation of nearly half the
historic mangrove cover in South and
Southeast Asia mangroves on the other
hand are much more than just habitats to
the fishing cat they are home to a
fantastic array of species like jackals
Turtles shorebirds and otters
mangroves also prevents soil erosion and
they can be the first line of defense
between storm surges tsunamis and the
millions of people who live next to
these forests for their day-to-day
survival the fact that puts the icing on
the cake or the earth I should say is
that mangroves can store upwards of five
to ten times more carbon dioxide than
tropical forests so protecting one acre
of mangroves may well be like protecting
five or more acres of tropical forests
would you like to eliminate your entire
life's carbon footprint
well mangroves can offer you one of the
best banks for your conservation buck
deforestation extinction and climate
change are all global problems that we
can solve by giving value to our species
and ecosystems and by working together
with the local people who live next to
them this is one of three river deltas
in coastal south india where communities
came together to change the face and
potentially the fate of this planet in
less than a decade with international
support the State Forest departments and
the local communities work together to
restore over 20,000 acres of
unproductive fish and shrimp farms back
into mangroves about five years ago
guess who rediscovered in these restored
mangroves when we shared images of these
fishing cats with local people we were
able to build pride among them about a
globally revered endangered species and
ecosystem in their backyards we were
also able to build trust with some
people to help them lead alternative
livelihoods meet Santosh a 19 year old
boy who not only became a conservation
professional after working with us for
just over a year but also went on to
involve many local fishermen in helping
study and protect fishing cats meet
moshe a tribal poacher who not only
stopped hunting and became our most
prized
conservationist but also used his
traditional knowledge to educate his
entire community to stop hunting fishing
cats otters and the many other
threatened species that live in the
mangroves in his backyard fish and
shrimp farmers like venket are now
willing to work with us conservationists
to test the sustainable harvest of
ecosystem services like crabs and
possibly even honey for mangroves
incentives that could get them to
protect and plant mangroves where they
have been lost a win-win-win for fishing
cats local people and the global
community these stories show us that we
can all be part of a future where
fishing cats and the lost mangrove
forests are protected and restored by
fishermen themselves creating carbon
sinks that can help offset our
ecological footprints so while the
fishing cat may be small I hope that
we've been able to help make it a big
deal one that we can all invest in to
help sustain our lives on Earth a little
longer or as our friend here would say
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]